it's my great pleasure to to introduce
my good friend dave rubin
thank you
that was pretty good i have a torn acl
in my left knee and i just hopped the
stage for you guys that's uh
that's pretty solid uh i quickly just
wanna uh offer some of that that decency
right back to you because i think
there's been three people who have
probably affected my thinking the most
in these last say five years or so uh
jordan peterson of course who everybody
knows who i toured with for a year and a
half who just if you're around that if
you're around that intellectual
powerhouse and that
that just energy of personal
responsibility and setting yourself
right before you set the world right
back if that doesn't change you in a
year and a half then nothing also i
would say jordan i would say of course
dennis prager who has become a good
friend and confidant of mine uh
and you your own you've really done that
for me you've helped me crystallize my
thinking in a way
that a guy who literally five years ago
believe it or not i was a bernie sanders
supporter
you can do if you want that's fine
that's fine
but i was i was you can see videos of it
on youtube and here i am at the national
conservatism conference and not only am
i here but i'm very happy to be here and
i'm very i'm actually very excited to be
here uh i should tell you guys also that
i come
from a place
called california
now you can really if you want to go
it's a horrible horrible place
i may not go back this might be it for
me i'm going to just stay in disney
world i think that would be fun yeah
i've had a lot of people offer me their
homes actually in florida people are
people are very nice um but there is
something happening in the world we know
something happening and it's and it's
something quite horrific it is something
that has happened before
and something that if we do what we are
supposed to do and if this conference
can piece together some
of
the ideas here of how we can sort of
blend what i would say are our good
classical liberal traditions
with true conservative principles i
think we can actually stem some of the
onslaught that is coming
you know five or six years ago when i
considered myself on the left and i
started saying you know guys we liberals
why are we shouting down all the
speakers why are we calling everyone
racist why are we calling everyone
homophobes this can't be this this
doesn't make sense we're not defending
our own principles we're not defending
free speech all this stuff a lot of the
pushback that i would get and there was
plenty of it was oh dave you know this
is just on college campuses don't worry
it's just a bunch of blue haired college
kids and they're not going to do
anything and the line that i would
always hear of course was you know when
they hit the real world when they hit
the real world then they'll figure out
what's what and i think if we've seen
anything in these last five years it's
that the real world folded pretty
quickly pretty freaking quickly and it's
on all of us and i would include myself
in that we did
something wrong i think something
happened
uh and i think perhaps
it's we're watching the end of the
liberal order that
just freedom for the sake of freedom
with nothing else behind it and nothing
eternal it does not work you end up
indoctrinating your own children to not
know what gender they are and then you
push racism into the system in the name
of anti-racism we all know something is
not right everyone knows it and we have
to do a better job defending it so that
really is why i'm so
proud to be here and i i think you know
the next part for all of us will be
not just talking about these things but
figuring out how we're going to
incorporate them into our lives to fight
back
so you know we did my tech company
locals we just merged with rumble this
week as i'm sure many of you heard and i
think this is one of the moments that we
will remember as a moment that we fought
against big tech because it's not just
college professors we're fighting and
it's not just democratic politicians and
it's not just brian stelter and don
lemon i wish we had a better class of
enemies sometimes
but it's not just these people it is now
fueled by big tech algorithms that are
that are silencing us and de-platforming
us and making sure that you know they
they uh what do they do they de-rank
things and they unbiased search results
they're doing all sorts of things and as
i often say on the show
it's not the ways that they're
manipulating us that we know about that
i'm really worried about it's the ways
that they're manipulating us that we
have no idea and i assure you they exist
so the move that we made this week was
to strengthen the fight and and i say
that not as self-promotion for locals or
rumble but i say that as something that
every one of us every one of you in this
room and everyone you're going to talk
to outside of this your family members
the people you work with we have to stop
participating in the lie we are we are
really
close to that final precipice like it
will all just go away
you know it doesn't matter what you
think about vaccines per se
it doesn't matter what you think about
trans issues it really doesn't what this
is all coming down to is will you be
able to exist on planet earth in a
western society with some level of
choice for yourself
and a lot of people are just kind of
saying no they can inject my child with
whatever they want they can tell me what
to do they can tell me to stay home they
can keep me in a mask forever and we're
watching it happen and and now you can
sort of see you know we live in this
weird time where everybody's everybody's
called a nazi right all of us i'm sure
everyone in this room has been called a
nazi they've butchered language in such
a
profoundly horrific way but i think
something that we now also see in these
last couple years is not just that the
world folded
as quickly as it did and the
institutions that were supposed to
defend us decided to get in on the
madness
it's not just that it's that you can now
sort of see how the nazis came to power
right we can all sort of see it i don't
think i could see it four years ago but
now you can kind of see it because we're
othering people oh those people not only
are they racist but now they're diseased
and they're going to kill you and the
rest of it so we are finding something
truly extraordinary but i will say this
because every day on my show i i you
know i cover the news and i try not to
have people depressed at the end there's
enough channels on where you can be
depressed or angry or you know you gotta
drink through them or whatever it is
and i
truly truly believe we can turn this
thing around
we really can but it's gonna take work
it's gonna be what i said before about
we have to stop participating in the lie
whatever that means in your own life to
just stop and start fighting back
whatever that means to you
and then it's to build new things so
we're already doing that on the tech
side and then more than more than
anything else especially if you're
someone that attends a conference like
this
start telling people what you think
start telling people what you think i
have no doubt that every single person
in this room is involved in many
relationships that your friends don't
know what you really think about the
world that your family members don't
know what you think about politics and i
don't mean that because politics should
be religion politics should not be
religion but people that are in your
circle should know what you think and
the more that we sit there quietly and
acquiesce to their madness the more they
will take they will take and it will be
on all of us so we'll do this conference
next year and things will be worse
so my job
as
i understand it is to communicate some
of these ideas to you guys and then my
hope is that your job is to take that
into your life and do something with it
so i'm very excited about the next few
days uh i'm honored to be part of this
and i hope everyone enjoys the
conference and oh
let's go brandon
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell